show me something draft who is it that
we
expect need want to step up and do what
it takes to help his team in this case
not just get a win but advance to a
conference championship game peter you
get the first pick
uh mike my first pick in this draft is
going to be the green bay packers
um i just think right now they are
uh
they're playing at home and all i would
want to do
is i would want their defense as a
collective
as a collective group to show me
something because they should be able to
hold
the los angeles rams to 14 or less and
there's no way
they think that aaron rodgers won't
score in the 20s so to me show me
something
the green bay packers defense as a whole
now i would be remiss if i don't point
out that chris sims pulls this from time
to time and my response is you can't say
the whole team you got to give us
somebody give me somebody
somebody on the defense jair alexander
jair alexander because here's what
here's what is going to happen in this
game at some point at some point
jared goff is going to have to throw the
ball downfield
and to me jair alexander he came within
this much of me voting for him for all
pro he's the best unknown defensive back
in the nfl and i would say jair
alexander show me something pick off a
ball help win this game
i i'm gonna go with tom brady because
look this is what he wanted this is why
he left this is why he picked the
buccaneers he could go anywhere he chose
he found a spot where he thought he
could go in and compete for a
championship right away he wants to
stick it to bill belichick he wants to
show he can win without him getting to
the round of eight
and getting to the final four
and maybe if you get to the final four
you punch your ticket to the super bowl
and this is tom brady rectifying week
one rectifying week nine when they got
rectified by the saints 38 to 3. this is
his chance to go into the superdome
death blow to drew brees career sorry
but that's part of the motivation and
take your team to the nfc championship
and it's all going to be on him it's
either going to be he got it done or he
didn't get it done we're not going to be
talking about anybody else from the
tampa bay buccaneers if they win or if
they lose it's all going to be brady
show me something patrick mahomes last
four games he played this year all under
100 passer rating and everybody's gonna
say well big deal well patrick mahomes
two-thirds of the games in his career
you know he's been over a hundred even
going back to
uh you know early on in his career
so it it means something it means
something
that these the the kansas city offense
struggled mightily
uh to win against four and 12 atlanta in
his last game so he's had 20 days to
figure out what is going on he's been
sitting around with eric b enemy with
andy reid with mike kafka
they have really tried to figure it out
and this is a brilliant coaching staff
so i think they probably have figured it
out but he's going to have to do it
against a young
hungry miles garrett led defense show me
something patrick mahomes
show me something devonte adams the
packers receiver likely will be covered
extensively if not exclusively by rams
cornerback jaylen ramsey you got to get
open or
if you're not open and aaron rodgers
tries to thread the needle you got to
make the catch but the packers chances
of winning this game will be
dramatically enhanced by the ability of
devante adams to get open catch the ball
get some yards after the catch score a
touchdown or two that's when you know
things are going well for the packers if
it's going to hinge offensively on
devonta adams peter
show me something matt milano and mike i
can't say the buffalo defense so i'm
gonna pick out one player and matt
milano is sort of your spy guy
on the buffalo defense and he is the one
who has got to avoid
being made to look silly by lamar
jackson when he takes off out of the
pocket it was very interesting watching
all of the various uh
tv productions on the espn mega cast the
other day
uh you should have heard rex ryan
keyshawn johnson teddy brewski
tear apart
the tennessee defense on that long
touchdown run
up by lamar jackson well
lamar jackson is going to do it again
uh at some point i don't know if it's
going to be a touchdown but he's going
to leave the pocket and have some open
space
and the matt milanos of the world one of
the first draft choices
of sean mcdermott when he became the
head coach
is going to have to be at the tip of the
spear of the buffalo defense
to really make lamar jackson feel it
when he leaves the pocket
i hate to go back to a game that i've
already picked someone from
but i can't ignore the glaring show me
something sign that is parked over the
head of drew brees
because this may be it for drew brees
right you said it earlier in the show
you don't want your career to end with a
loss in the superdome to tom brady you
don't want it to go out this way you
want to walk off into the sunset with
super bowl trophy number two all these
guys that have won
all these quarterbacks with one peter
are so obsessed with getting to number
two think of all the great quarterbacks
out there who have won drew brees
russell wilson aaron rodgers patrick
mahomes they got one and what they want
more than anything else is two there's a
different there's a different feel to
your career when you get to breeze the
first battle hall of famer either way
but
getting to two is is something i'm sure
he's obsessed with especially because
he's he's so intensely competitive this
is not the way he wants to go out
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports